wow thank you so much it is great great
to be with you always a pleasure to be
in Kentucky I'm looking forward to lots
and lots of bourbon after tonight's
event
it was I was strongly considering
sampling the local fair when I first
arrived here today but I decided it
would be better not to give this speech
in cursive tonight so I'm going to wait
I want to thank the students here at the
University of Kentucky for the
invitation thank you to yaff as always
for hosting and thank you to the TW
Lewis foundation for sponsoring this
event
I'm very grateful to all of you and so I
will hold off on the bourbon until just
after the speech
the other reason why it would probably
have been a bad idea to show up hammered
for tonight's event is that it would
have given the libs yet another excuse
to write off everything that we say is
crazy
that they're going to do that anyway
that's what they always do when
conservatives cite facts and make sound
logical arguments they do that because
they have no logical arguments of their
own so when they're not calling us
racists and fascists and terrorists
they're calling us nuts and Kooks and
conspiracy theorists
now that last one that is my favorite
one
because it is so incredibly effective
it doesn't mean anything but it's very
very effective
after racist conspiracy theorist is
probably the single worst thing that you
can be called in our society
the minute that you get labeled a
conspiracy theorist pretty much
everything that you have to say ceases
to be taken seriously by the left
certainly but even by many in the center
and on the right
yet easy as it is to destroy someone
with accusations of conspiracy theorism
the same as with accusations of racism
it is much easier to ruin someone by
calling him a conspiracy theorist than
it is to Define precisely what a
conspiracy theory is
a number of conspiracy theories have
cropped up in recent years particularly
regarding covid maybe you've heard of
some of them for instance in the early
days of coven
there was a conspiracy theory that kovid
most likely originated at a Chinese
laboratory and not in nature or in a bad
bowl of bat soup
now all of the established scientific
and political authorities Dr fauci
Rachelle wolenski the CDC director Joe
Biden all of them the entire
establishment media they all denounced
this Theory as crazy absurd
scientifically impossible
then after a year and a half of
denouncing it when the evidence in
support of the theory became undeniable
they quietly admitted that it was true
now once the authorities admitted that
the virus most likely came from the
Chinese lab another conspiracy theory
cropped up
the theory that the United States had
actually funded the sort of research
associated with viruses like covid-19 at
the very laboratory where the virus
originated
this conspiracy theory this was
outrageous
not only did the serious credible
scientific authorities in all the very
fancy lab coats denounced this Theory
but Dr fauci himself denied it under
penalty of perjury before the U.S Senate
now of course that was before a Freedom
of Information Act request produced the
receipts showing that the United States
had in fact funded the risky research on
bat coronaviruses with specific
sub-grants for the Wuhan Institute of
virology and guess who signed off on the
funding you'll never guess now you will
guess it was Dr fauci it's amazing that
he's so smart he's such a genius his
memory not so great I guess a little bit
of a selective memory that Dr fauci
now after that crazy covid conspiracy
theory turned out to be true
another one emerged this being the crazy
conspiracy theory that the covid
vaccines were neither totally safe nor
particularly effective this is when
YouTube turns us off by the way so good
night everybody lovely to be with you
hope you've enjoyed four minutes of my
speech but
that's when they get you so from the
moment that the vaccines became
available to the public the established
authorities all insisted that they were
safe and totally effective
Biden fauci wolensky they all promised
that the shots would prevent infection
and transmission of the virus quote
you're not going to get covid if you
have these vaccinations Joe Biden fauci
assured us when people are vaccinated
they can feel safe that they are not
going to get infected
Rochelle walensky insisted vaccinated
people do not I don't do a good walensky
so I'll just put that back in my regular
voice wilensky insisted vaccinated
people do not carry the virus do not get
sick
on the one side you had just about every
single established Authority in the
country on the other side you had the
crazy conspiracy theorists guess who was
right
the conspiracy theorists 100 percent
the established authorities zero percent
the authorities told us that the
vaccines were totally safe
they told us that reports of vaccine
injuries were
a crazy conspiracy theory
then people started coming down with
blood clots and myocarditis and changes
to women's menstrual cycles that one
that last one we were told by the public
health propagandists was scientifically
impossible and then I don't know it just
started happening then the so-called
conspiracy theory turned out to be true
and according to recent studies fairly
widespread
did you see just this week just happened
I think yesterday
a writer in the Atlantic called for a
pandemic amnesty did you see that
let's declare a pandemic amnesty the
author wrote we need to forgive one
another for what we did and said when we
were in the dark about covid
yeah
for over two years the libs destroyed
our economy usurped our rights kept our
kids out of school left our loved ones
to die alone forced us to inject
ourselves with a dangerous and
experimental drug or lose our jobs and
label this all conspiracy theorists to
justify kicking us out of the Public
Square when we rightly contradicted
their false narrative
but that was then and this is now you
see this very that would that was okay
that was back then when the libs had 100
of the power now though we're headed
into the midterm elections Republicans
might get a tiny little bit of power and
so you know let's
just let's say it's we're even okay the
conservatives were tormented the libs
did the tormenting we all did stuff okay
you know and let's just forget about it
right
right I don't think so tribunals
actually is what I'm responding to that
offer with you're you are offering
amnesty okay that's interesting I'm
hearing that I am going to respond to
that with military tribunals that's my
negotiating position let's see maybe
where it has that sound
Justice would be a good I digress I
digress we're already kicked off YouTube
so we can say whatever we want
we could go on about the Vindication of
covid conspiracy theories all night we
have barely scratched the surface
and that is just covet
imagine that that is just one part
of one example from just the past few
years there are so many others
I've got one how about this crazy
conspiracy theory you may have heard of
that the Democrats rigged the 2020
election have you heard about that
Looney Tune idea
the notion that the Democrats you say is
crazy that the Democrats changed all of
the election rules right before the
election in some cases illegally to
disadvantage Donald Trump and the
Republicans and to give the Democrats an
advantage that we were told was
completely insane to the delusions of
tin foil hat clad lunatics
until the Liberals themselves admitted
that they had done it
they admitted it on February 4th 2021
Time Magazine published an account a
very detailed account of the way that
they rigged the election it was called
the secret history of the Shadow
campaign that saved the 2020 election
here's just a little sampling from that
essay
in a way Trump was right
there was a conspiracy unfolding behind
the scenes one that both curtailed the
protests and coordinated the resistance
from CEOs both surprises were the result
of an informal alliance between
left-wing activists and business Titans
the handshake between business and labor
was just one component of a vast
cross-partisan campaign their work
touched every aspect of the election
they got states to change voting systems
and laws and helped secure hundreds of
millions in public and private funding
they fended off voter suppression
lawsuits they recruited armies of poll
workers they got millions of people to
vote by mail for the first time they
successfully pressured social media
companies to take a harder line against
disinformation and use data-driven
strategies to fight viral smears they
executed national public awareness
campaigns that helped Americans
understand how the vote count would
unfold over days and weeks just had to
had to explain to Americans why we can't
count our vote it's as quickly as Brazil
does you know as as quickly as tin pot
dictatorships in Latin America no It's
Perfectly Normal it just takes days and
weeks to count the votes because you
understand the Democrats need to figure
out how many votes they need and then
once they get that number then it's very
easy to find the balance
it's right there in black and white
folks this is not the ravings of a
Madman this is not my own theory on how
things work this this is the words of
the Liberals themselves published in a
very mainstream liberal Outlet
not so much a conspiracy theory as a
confession
of a conspiracy
now I suspect many people in this room
could could recite a Litany of famous
conspiracy theories that turned out to
be true I bet you could do it right off
the top of your heads
here's this is a very famous One the
Tuskegee experiments
1932 the U.S Public Health Service
conspired with the Tuskegee Institute to
create a fake medical program the
program purported to treat syphilis but
instead it administered dangerous
chemicals and procedures to roughly 400
black male participants
only in the 1970s did the government cop
to this conspiracy and pay out 10
million dollars plus Lifetime Health
benefits to the men that it had
exploited
how about a slightly lesser known
conspiracy this one's fairly recent too
though
the naira testimony
do you remember that does anyone
remember in the room the night you're a
testimony a lot of people actually don't
know about this one the naira testimony
was 1990 a 15 year old girl using the
pseudonym naira testified before
Congress that after the Iraqi invasion
of Kuwait Iraqi soldiers had taken
Kuwaiti babies out of incubators and and
left them to die on the hospital room
floors and and watched it and sort of
mocked these babies as they died this
testimony was cited countless times by
the bush White House to justify American
involvement in the Gulf War
turned out the story was completely made
up and it wasn't just accidentally made
up it was made up by a PR firm that
worked with the bush White House
it was made up very likely in
coordination with the White House itself
how about the gay frogs
remember the gay frogs that's that is
100 my favorite conspiracy theory that
turned out to be true when Alex Jones
said on air they're turning the freaking
frogs gay
and then everybody made fun of him
and then he was totally right
whatever Alex Jones has ever said in his
life it is simply a fact
they were turning the freaking frogs gay
there was a team of scientists from Yale
that analyzed 21 Pawns in Suburban
Connecticut
and found actually not only were they
turning the frogs gay they were turning
them trans
estrogenic waste in the in the water in
these ponds was turning the frogs
hermaphroditic So Not only was Alex
Jones's crazy conspiracy theory true it
actually didn't go far enough he was
actually too modest in his commentary
now of course any list of conspiracy
theories turning out to be true is going
to have to include a healthy dose of
mentions of the CIA the CIA would not be
doing its job if it did not turn out on
such a list some of these are famous
some of these are Infamous some of these
you've never heard of
there is of course the usual fare of
assassinating world leaders and covering
that up that that has been well
documented but there are certain CIA
conspiracies that took place on American
soil itself
a very well-known one would be MK Ultra
which is extremely weird coincidentally
also my nickname I would like I think
that's a good nickname MK Ultra so the
thing I'm going to try to make that
happen
the the MK Ultra conspiracy was the
conspiracy of the CIA to ply unwitting
Americans and Canadians with LSD and
then to pay off hospitals and prisons
and universities to keep quiet about it
that conspiracy was not discovered until
1975.
it was two years after CIA director
Richard Helms ordered that all the
documents pertaining to MK Ultra be
destroyed though a 1977 Freedom of
Information Act request did uncover some
20 000 remaining documents to Aid in the
work of the church committee and the
president's Commission on CIA activities
in the U.S
then there's operation Mockingbird that
one again very basic it was the very
effective CIA campaign to control the
messaging coming out of the New York
Times and Newsweek and CBS and lots of
other news outlets this is
run-of-the-mill stuff I don't think does
anyone in this room believe the New York
Times is a serious journalistic Outlet I
don't think so frankly I wish they were
spending more time on CIA propaganda
some of the stuff that they run is much
worse than that
some of it was less run-of-the-mill
though
conspiracies such as operation
Northwoods a 1962 CIA proposal to launch
a false flag attack on American Military
and civilian targets and then blame it
on Fidel Castro and then channel that
outrage to to launch a war against Cuba
that particular conspiracy thankfully
never went into effect because the
Kennedy administration rejected it but
the top secret document outlining the
proposal has been Declassified it was
Declassified in 1997 it's available in
plain English for anyone to read it
sounds completely insane but you can
look it up you can read the actual
document
operation Northwoods is about as crazy a
conspiracy theory as one could possibly
think up
and yet it happens to be true
putting the CIA aside for a moment we
learned just yesterday about a new sort
of operation Mockingbird this time
coming out of the Department of Homeland
Security is happening right now
according to reporting from The
Intercept in the lead up to the 2020
election big tech companies including
not just Twitter and Facebook but Reddit
Discord Wikipedia Microsoft LinkedIn and
a number of others met on a monthly
basis
with the FBI with the cyber security and
infrastructure Security Agency
and with other government
Representatives
these meetings did not just concern
technology hacking that sort of thing
the meetings concerned disinformation
and by disinformation I of course mean
information that was harmful to
Democrats
Twitter and Facebook had Direct portals
for the government to request that
inconvenient information be censored
direct portals they could go to
according to documents filed in federal
court in a lawsuit brought by the
attorney's General of Missouri and
Louisiana two FBI agents Elvis Chan and
Laura demlow were involved in high-level
communication with tech Executives that
quote led to Facebook's suppression of
the hunter Biden laptop story The Hunter
Biden laptop story which was suppressed
by all the big Tech platforms which
according to post-election polls
single-handedly could have swung the
election to Trump
why was that story stopped because of
phone calls from the FBI
it was a conspiracy plain and simple
so if You observe historical facts
does that make you a conspiracy theorist
I guess it does you are putting forward
a theory about a conspiracy but in the
case of all the examples that I just
cited and countless others on top of
that you would be theorizing about
about conspiracies that indisputably
occurred
when a conspiracy theory is demonstrably
true who could deny it
only a fool
or a liar or a coward
and I think it's that latter category
there that that explains and describes
most people in whom the phrase
conspiracy theory still inspires fear
and dread
the sort of people who knew from the
beginning that the official story on
kovid's Origins didn't really make a lot
of sense
the people who suspected that the
vaccines were probably not quite as safe
and effective as we were told
the people who sense intuitively that
there were some serious structural
Shenanigans in the 2020 elections
widespread mail-in ballots in
contravention of the Pennsylvania state
constitution to cite just one example
people who suspect all of those things
but don't dare raise the suggestion
because they fear for their social media
accounts or for their jobs or just their
social standing
which depends upon going along to get
along and denying what what one can see
with one's own eyes
people who understand that the true
function of the label conspiracy
theorist is not to separate truth from
fantasy but rather simply to get
dissidents to shut up
when did this fear of conspiracy
theorizing begin not all that long ago
it turns out a Google engram analysis
reveals that the term conspiracy theory
appeared basically nowhere in the
English language until the mid-1930s and
it only really took off after 1950. the
term conspiracy theorist is of an even
more recent vintage appearing basically
nowhere until the mid 60s not really
taking off until 1990. I mentioned
earlier that the term conspiracy
theorist fulfills a similar function to
the word racist that is it's an
accusation that when successfully
applied completely destroys a man's
reputation in the Public Square
it's a label that means a little more
than this person is bad and or stupid
and you should not take him seriously
the word racist follows almost exactly
the same historical pattern of usage
racism and racist appeared pretty much
nowhere until the mid-30s they became
popular only after 1950. in other words
these two terms of abuse these
linguistic weapons only came into
fashion during the era of the post-war
liberal consensus and during that entire
time they have been used almost
exclusively to attack conservatives
liberals have a much worse record on
Race than than conservatives do a much
more perverse view of race doesn't
matter the stench of racism only ever
sticks to conservatives
but Joe Biden says that Barack Obama is
the first clean articulate black man in
American politics doesn't matter
the Democrat Party founds and runs the
KKK for the entirety of its existence as
an organization doesn't matter
but if a conservative criticizes George
Soros the most prominent and prolific
funder of far-left causes in the world
that conservative will instantly be
labeled an anti-semite a conspiracy of
theorists too actually if a conservative
criticizes Barack Obama he will
instantly be labeled a racist
and the same goes for conspiracy
theories think of the Absurd narratives
that the mainstream liberal
establishment has tried to sell us in
recent years it's amazing to think back
and remember that this actually happened
they told us for years on end that
Donald Trump
Donald Trump the man that we've all
known since what the 80s or earlier
Donald the guy in Home Alone you know
the guy that saved the ice rink in New
York Donald Trump was secretly a Russian
asset some kind of sleeper KGB agent who
was going to do Putin's bidding because
Putin had a videotape of him urinating
on prostitutes in Moscow
they took they it wasn't crazy radical
well they were crazy and radical but it
was the mainstream liberals who told us
this for years on all the mainstream
news outlets
never mind that Donald Trump has been
the most hard-line president on Russia
in my lifetime
never mind that Donald Trump is the only
President since Vladimir Putin's rise to
power on whose watch Vladimir Putin did
not invade a Sovereign Nation it's kind
of weird isn't it George W bush Putin
invades Georgia Barack Obama Putin
invades Ukraine Donald Trump
we just kind of chill you know and then
Joe Biden Putin goes even further into
Ukraine
never mind that these guys could not
produce a single shred of evidence for
their insane conspiracy theory they just
peddled it for years and years and then
when it completely fell apart during the
Mueller investigation they just moved on
as if nothing had happened
they're going to call for amnesty
they're going to call for a truce never
mind never mind that we undermine the
administration move on never mind yet
the left
bill has the audacity to accuse the
right increasingly of embracing
conspiracy theories
perhaps we are
but if there is a rise in conspiracy
theorizing on the right it is not due to
any defect in the rational faculties of
conservatives
it is due to a rise in actual
conspiracies on the left
conspiracy theories flourish when people
lose trust in their political
institutions as we are seeing today but
the collapse and credibility of our
institutions is not the fault of
conservatives it is the fault of the
liberals who have controlled those
institutions for decades and run them
into the ground
to be a conspiracy theorist during times
of political order and transparency is
kooky and ridiculous
but to be a conspiracy theorist
during times of profuse conspiracy is
rational and prudent
in an age such as ours the difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is often not the difference
between delusion and reality
as our liberal ruling class has shown so
clearly over the past few years in an
age such as ours the real difference
between a conspiracy theory and the
truth is about three to six months thank
you very much
[Applause]